est ce que vous êtes riche bien verrière
mais quoi non j'ai pas grand chose je
vis avec ce que je gagne ou journée
choix quand vous avez vendu votre
propriété dupré versailles offre mx 5
hectares quand même c'est bien de
toucher de l'argent mais j'avais des
dettes et je venais de divorcer et
contrairement à ce qu'on pense
un divorce américain ça peut coûter cher
que l'or c'est ma part apporté dessoudé
tout le contraire et dans ces moments là
quand vous avez vraiment besoin d'argent
est ce que vous avez pensé à faire de la
publicité
non non j'ai fait des émissions de radio
radio monte car j'ai raconté la vie des
stars je voyageais beaucoup c'était
assez étonnant d'ailleurs c'était une
période où j'avais pas un rond j'ai même
pas de quoi prendre un taxi
j'ai pas tellement longtemps 180 et
j'étais invité partout alors on faisait
un hommage à jeanne moreau à san
francisco un autre à chicago j'étais
invité à boston je voyager en première
classe gt habillé par les grands
couturiers qui prêtait des vêtements et
j'étais logé dans des palaces et
heureusement que j'avais des amis ou
comme invitée à dîner mais je pouvais
sans descendre de l'avion veut plus
urgents non mais la vie est formidable
parce que j'ai trouvé sur mon chemin où
des gens sont menées à ma rencontre et
je n'ai jamais désespérer il y avait
toujours quelqu'un qui me donnait 100
francs ou ça s'emballe et
ça s'est toujours bien passé